almost 10 years ago disaster rocked the
already impoverished nation of Haiti the
earthquake left hundreds of thousands of
people dead and injured
now United Nations peacekeepers there to
help are accused of adding to the harm a
study claims they fathered hundreds of
babies then abandoned the young mothers
some only children themselves we had
plenty of stories of peacekeepers
engaging with with young young girls and
young women under the age of 18 which is
of course as we all know statutory rape
her research found evidence of
peacekeepers allegedly trading food and
money for sex one woman even told
researchers I see a series of females 12
and 13 years old here peacekeepers
impregnated and left them in misery with
babies in their hands Haiti's government
called the report's findings distressing
and deplorable the UN said allegations
against peacekeepers there have been
generally declining since 2013 it said
it remains committed to addressing and
resolving cases of sexual exploitation
and abuse committed by its personnel and
supporting victims and their families
but the UN will not always be aware of
abuses carried out by its peacekeepers
around the world what you're talking
about in those situations is asking
sometimes children 14 15 year olds who
are in very vulnerable precarious
situations themselves to come forward to
an international organization that is in
league with their government that often
does not literally speak their language
in any meaningful sentence and report
somebody who is in a position of power
over them and over their lives in Haiti
the UN says it's providing support to 32
babies conceived by peacekeepers but
this latest research suggests the number
of victims is much higher Deborah Haynes
Sky News